hola este es el vídeo de química
esencial número 27 y hablaremos de las
ecuaciones moleculares iónicas iónicas
netas en química siempre estamos
observando algo imaginen que observamos
un mechero de punxín y queremos saber
cuáles son los químicos que se combinan
en una reacción de combustión entonces
primero escribimos la reacción
balanceada y después dependiendo del
tipo de reacción que tengamos usamos
diferentes tipos de ecuaciones así que
empecemos con la combustión de metal lo
que sale de un mechero de punxín es
metano gaseoso ch4 consiste en un átomo
de carbono y 4 átomos de hidrógeno y se
combina con oxígeno molecular que
consiste en dos átomos de oxígeno así es
como ocurre la combustión pero qué se
produce en esta reacción bueno se
produce dióxido de carbono y agua
ahora pasa algo muy raro porque miren no
hay tantos hidrógenos del lado derecho a
comparación de los que teníamos del lado
izquierdo así que necesitamos agregar
otra molécula de agua del lado derecho y
así es como podemos empezar a balancear
la ecuación química ya estamos bien con
los hidrógenos pero ahora tenemos muchos
oxígenos del lado derecho así que
necesitamos agregar otra molécula de
oxígeno del lado izquierdo
ya tenemos una ecuación química
balanceada simplemente nos fijamos en el
número de átomos y esto qué significa
bueno significa que en la combustión de
metano un molde metano reacciona con dos
moléculas de oxígeno molecular para
producir un molde dióxido de carbono y
dos moles de agua esa es nuestra
ecuación balanceada entonces en química
primero observamos algo escribimos los
átomos que participan en la reacción y
después pasan
la ecuación química entonces si tenemos
un cambio químico recuerde es un cambio
en el que se rompen y se forman nuevos
enlaces entonces podemos escribir una
ecuación química que represente todo eso
y tiene que estar balanceada para que
podamos usar especialmente cuando
analizamos la stec yo metería entonces
una ecuación general es la ecuación
molecular esa es la ecuación química que
han usado toda su vida pero hay otras
dos ecuaciones que son muy importantes
una es la iónica a la que también se le
conoce como ecuación iónica completa
ésta es muy importante sobre todo cuando
trabajamos con iones disueltos en
solución acuosa y después tenemos a la
ecuación iónica neta que nos permite ver
únicamente a los átomos que son más
importantes y este tipo de ecuación es
muy importante cuando trabajamos con
reacciones redux pero al final con
cualquiera de estas ecuaciones podemos
estudiar las partes
las que intervienen en la reacción
química y así podemos entender lo que
está sucediendo y recuerden la química
es una ciencia de laboratorio así que
podemos observar algo en el laboratorio
y después llegamos a una de estas
ecuaciones ahora una buena forma de
jugar con el balanceo de ecuaciones
químicas es con simulaciones como por
ejemplo la de ph te miren aquí pueden
colocar los moles en este caso se
produce amoniaco y vamos a suponer que
tenemos un molde cada uno pero no está
balanceada del lado izquierdo tenemos
mucho nitrógeno pero ya se lo podemos
balancear con hidrógeno y si ya nos sale
la carita feliz porque tenemos el mismo
número de átomos en los dos lados
entonces recuerde para balancear una
ecuación no pueden cambiar las moléculas
pero si pueden cambiar el coeficiente
que las acompaña ahora estamos con
disociación de agua y como en este caso
tenemos mucho
y geno del lado derecho simplemente lo
balanceamos con hidrógeno del otro lado
y ahora si analizamos la combustión de
metano primero ponemos uno de cada uno y
podemos ver que no tenemos suficiente
hidrógeno del lado izquierdo
así que balanceamos eso del lado derecho
y balanceando el oxígeno todos son
felices lo divertido de esto es que una
vez que ya lo entendieron pueden ir al
juego de balanceo en el que les darán
diferentes ecuaciones químicas algunas
serán fáciles algunas no tanto pero
pueden jugar y cuando crean que ya están
lo pueden checar y si están bien les
saldrá a la carita feliz y podrán
continuar con la siguiente el juego mide
el tiempo y es muy divertido
entonces balancear ecuaciones químicas
es muy importante y es algo que siempre
deben hacer cuando trabajen con uno pero
volvamos al mechero de ponce lo primero
que deben hacer es observar y después
pueden tratar de describir lo que sucede
por ejemplo
el metano se quema en presencia de
oxígeno produciendo dióxido de carbono y
vapor de agua y después escribimos los
reactivos y los productos y después hay
que balancear la ecuación entonces
podemos escribir los coeficientes y
asegurarnos de que tenemos el mismo
número de átomos en los dos lados y
bueno algo que también podemos incluir
para que nuestra ecuación se vea
elegante son los estados es decir en
esta reacción combinamos gases para
producir dióxido de carbono gaseoso y
vapor de agua entonces esta es nuestra
ecuación molecular y la podemos usar
para estudiar este que o metría o para
mediciones pero ahora veamos qué pasa
con una reacción que ocurre en solución
acuosa bueno en esta reacción tenemos
una solución de nitrato de plomo que es
transparente y le vamos a agregar una
solución de yoduro de potasio con lo que
se produce un precipitado amarillo
obtenemos un sólido
es nada más observando ya sabemos cuáles
son los químicos que intervienen y ahora
vamos a escribirlo tenemos una solución
de nitrato de plomo que agregamos a una
solución de yoduro de potasio y
obtenemos un precipitado amarillo de
yoduro de plomo que se asienta en el
fondo ahora lo siguiente que podemos
hacer es escribir los reactivos y los
productos entonces primero escribimos
todos los reactivos y después todos los
productos entonces tenemos nitrato de
plomo + yoduro de potasio que producen
yoduro de plomo más nitrato de potasio
lo siguiente que podemos hacer es
asegurarnos de que la ecuación esté
balanceada y en este caso podemos ver
que no tenemos suficiente yodo del lado
izquierdo así que ponemos dos y también
necesitamos más nitrato del lado derecho
entonces escribimos 2
y después vamos a escribir el estado de
agregación en el que se encuentra
recuerden los reactivos se encontraban
en solución acuosa pero el yoduro de
plomo es un sólido esta es nuestra
ecuación molecular pero en este vídeo
también hablaremos de otras dos
ecuaciones las ecuaciones iónicas y las
ecuaciones iónicas netas pero eso es
como funciona bueno para una ecuación
iónica necesitamos pensar en iones
necesitamos pensar en el nitrato de
plomo no como una molécula en solución
porque en realidad se disocia es decir
se separa en iones iones de plomo y
iones nitrato
entonces para escribir una ecuación
iónica necesitamos escribir los guiones
primero tenemos el guión de plomo que
tiene una carga 2 positiva y después
tenemos 2 iones de nitrato que tienen
una carga 1 negativa el 2 es porque aquí
tenemos 2 nitratos entonces en una
ecuación johnny k
vemos las moléculas en guiones ahora
vamos con el siguiente aquí tenemos
yoduro de potasio que lo podemos separar
así y miren todo eso se encuentra en
solución acuosa pero recuerden que el
yoduro de plomo es sólido un sólido
amarillo así que no lo vamos a separar
lo escribimos tal y como está pero
después tenemos nitrato de potasio y ese
si se disocia lo escribimos así parece
mucho trabajo pero esta es la ecuación
johnny acá y es muy importante porque
nos ayuda a saber qué iones participan
en la reacción recuerden es una reacción
que ocurre en solución acuosa y también
se le conoce como ecuación iónica
completa porque nos muestra todos los
iones que tenemos presentes ok y cual
nos falta claro la ecuación johnny canet
miren si analizamos la ecuación iónica
podemos ver que tenemos dos iones
nitratos del lado izquierdo y dos iones
nitrato del lado derecho como
cambian a eso se les conoce como iones
espectadores lo que podemos hacer es
tachar los mientras tengamos lo mismo de
los dos lados podemos tachar o cancelar
los iones hay algo más que tengamos en
los dos lados así los iones potasio los
cancelamos ahora una vez que quitamos a
los iones espectadores nos queda esta
ecuación y esta es la ecuación iónica
net entonces esta es la ecuación
molecular y ahora voy a escribir la
ecuación johnny k pero dibujando las
moléculas aquí tenemos los iones de
plomo y los de nitrato así es como se
ven cuando están en solución recuerden
no están unidos están disueltos en agua
y después tenemos a los iones de potasio
y los de yoduro y también están
separados
estos son los iones yoduro y estos son
los iones de potasio ok y después cuando
ocurre la reacción nos queda el nitrato
de potasio pero en forma de iones de
potasio y iones nitrato
ya habíamos visto que son iones
espectadores no cambian y este es el
yoduro de plomo el sólido amarillo así
que esto es lo que en realidad estamos
representando en una ecuación johnny acá
y después para la ecuación iónica neta
solo nos muestran que tenemos iones de
plomo y iones yoduro que se combinan
para formar yoduro de plomo esa es la
forma simplificada lo aprendieron
aprendieron a interpretar un cambio
químico observado en una ecuación
química balanceada del tipo correcto
acuérdense hay tres tipos la ecuación
molecular que es la que ya conocen la
iónica que es cuando separamos todo en
iones y la iónica neta en la que
únicamente se muestran los iones
principales de la reacción espero que
les sirva